Speaking of solutions, this is the last little bit of thing
that you need to know. And that is. This defines a
problem. But, what we also want to have, whenever we have
a problem. Is a solution. So, the solution to the Markov
Decision Process, is something called a policy. And, what a policy
does. Is, it's a function, that takes in a state. And
returns an action, in other words, for any given state that
you're in, it tells you the action that you should take.
>> Like as a hint?
>> No, it just tells you, this is the at.
Well, I mean, I suppose you don't have to do
it, but the way we think about Markov Decision Processes,
is that this is the action that will be taken.
>> I see, so it's more of an order.
>> Yes, it's a command. Okay.
>> So that's all a policy is. A policy is
solution to a Markov Decision Process. And there is a
special policy, which I'm writing here as policy star, or
the optimal policy, and that is the policy that maximizes
your long-term expected reward. So if all the policies you
could take, of all the decisions you might take, this
is the policy that optimizes the amount of reward that
you're going to receive or expect to receive over your lifetime.
>> So, like, at the end?
>> Well, at yeah, at the end, or at
any given point in time, how much reward you're receiving.
>From the Markov Decision Process point of view, there doesn't
have to be an end. Okay. Though in this example,
you don't get anything, and then at the end, you get paid off.
>> Right, or unpaid off.
>> Right.
>> If you fall into the red square. So
actually, your question points out something very important here. I
mentioned earlier when I talked about the three kinds of
learning that there, supervised learning and reinforced learning were sort
of. Similar, except that instead of getting Ys and
Xs we were given Ys and, Xs and Zs. And
this is exactly what's happening here. Here what we would
like to have if we wanted to learn a policy
is a bunch of sa pairs as training examples. Well
here's the state and the action you should've took, taken, here's
another state and the action you should've taken, so on and
so forth. And then we would learn a function, the policy,
that maps states to actions. But what we actually see
in the reinforcement learning world, in the Markov Decision Process world,
is we see states, actions, and then the rewards that we
received. And so in fact, this problem of seeing a sequence
of states, actions, and rewards. It's very different
from the problem of being told. This is the
correct action to take to maximize a function.
Or find a function that maps from state to
action. Instead, we say well, if you're in
this state, and you take this action, this is
the reward that you would see. And then
from that, we need to find the optimal action.
>> So Pi star is being the F from that previous slide?
>> Right.
>> And R is being Z?
>> Yes. And y is being a.
>> And s is being x or x is being s
>> Got you.
>> Right.
>> So but, I'm, okay I'm a little confused
about this notion of a policy. So we have
the, the, the thing we tried to do to
get the goals was up, up, right, right, right. Yes.
>> I don't see how to capture that as a policy.
>> It's actually fairly straightforward. What a policy would say is:
What state are you in? Tell me what action you
should take. So, the policy, basically is this: When you're in
the state, start, the start state, the action you should take
is up. And it would have a mapping. For every state
that you might see, whether it's this state, this state,
this state, this state, this state, this state, this state, or
even these two states, and it will tell you what action
you should take. And that's what a policy is. A policy,
very simply, is nothing more than a function that tells you what
action to take at every, in any state you happen to come across.
>> Okay, but the, but the. The question that
you asked before was about up, up, right, right, right.
>> Mm hm.
>> And, it seems like, because of
the stochastic transitions. You might not be in
the same state. Like, you don't know what
state you're in, when you take those actions.
>> No, so, one of the things for what we're talking about
here, for the Markov Decision Process.
Is, there're states, there're actions, there're rewards.
You always know what state you're in, and you know what reward you receive.
>> So does that mean you can't do up, up right right right?
>> Well, the way it would work in a Markov Decision Process,
so what you're describing is is what's often called a plan. You
know, it's, tell me what sequence of actions I should take from
here. What Markov Decision Process does and what a pr, a policy
does is it doesn't tell you what sequence of actions to take from a particular
state. It tells you what action to take in a particular state. You will then
end up in another state because of
the transition model, the transition function. And then
when you're in that state you ask the
policy what actions should I take now? Okay.
>> Right, so this is actually a key point.
Although we talked about it in the language of planning,
which is very common for the people who di, for example
take any ag course, the thing about this in terms of planning,
what are the things that I can do to accomplish my
goals? The Markov Decision Process way of thinking about it, the reinforcement
way of thinking about it, or the typical reinforcement learning way
of thinking about it, really doesn't talk about plans directly. But instead,
talks about policies. Which from which you can infer a plan, but
this has the advantage that it tells you what to do everywhere.
And it's robust to the underlying stochastic of the word. World.
>> So, is it clear that's all you need to be able to behave well.
>> Well, it's certainly the case, that if you have a policy and that policy
is optimal, it does tell you what to do, no matter what situation you're in.
>> 'Kay.
>> And so, if you have that, then that's definitely
all you need to behave well. But I mean could it
be that you wanted to do something like up, up,
right, right, right which you cant write down as a policy?
>> And why cant
you write that down as a policy?
>> Because the policies are only telling you what action to do as a function
of the state not sort of like how far along you are in the sequence.
>> Right unless, of course, you fold that into your state some how. But thats
exactly right, the way to think about this is. The idea of coming up with
a concrete plan of what to do for the next 20 time steps is different
from the problem of whatever step I happen to be in, whatever state I happen
to be in, what's the next best thing
I can do? And just always asking that question.
>> Hm.
>> If you always ask that question,
that will induce a sequence, but that sequence
is actually dependent upon the set of states
that you see. Whereas in the other case
where we wrote down a particular policy, you'll
notice that was only dependent upon the state
you started in and it had to ignore the states that you saw along the way.
>> And the only way to fix that would be
to say, well, after I've taken an action, let me look at the state
I'm in and see if I should do something different with it. But if
you're going to do that, then why are you trying to compute the complete set
of states? Or I'm sorry, the complete set of actions that you might take.
>> Okay.
>> Okay, so there you go. Now, a lot
of what we're going to be talking about next Michael, is,
given that we have MDP, we have this Markov Decision
Process defined like this. How do we go from this
problem definition to finding a good policy, and
in particular, finding the optimal policy? That makes sense.
>> Good. And there you go.